j'ai perdu mon grand père a eu un
héritage c'est qu'on imaginait un
porte-clés ses bras portent que c'est un
talisman ce talisman permet de se
balader dans les dimensions alternative
de notre élite et peut-être l'existant
dimension tout me réussit et aux yeux de
tout le monde je suis une sorte de
perfection incarnée
arrêtez moi je suis personne moi
personne personne n'attend on devrait
rentrer ça va compliquer
[Musique]
non on attends j'ai utilisé ma force et
non mes mots pour sortir de la sttr pr
loïc là bas il ya une vraie qualité de
vie ok non non non et des dangers
c'était marqué sur loïc g s'te plaît ma
vie ici je n'aime pas je préfère ma vie
là-bas tu attendais ouais ouais ouais ça
serait une bonne idée je pense tu veux
bien non je veux pas non parce que le
talisman présente des dangers
donc ce que je vais faire c'est j'ai
passé toute la nuit dans cette
bibliothèque pour faire des recherches
ok parce qu'ici cette bibliothèque c'est
pas vraiment une bibliothèque c'est ma
maison et les employés ces maps et on
ferme casse toi fils de [ __ ] auquel j'ai
plutôt faire et recherche chez moi j'y
serai plus tranquille en attendant je
vais cacher le talisman dans un endroit
sucre pour moi ce que j'ai su que
personne n'osera dire un an déjà moi
j'avais déjà lu le double qu'en fait au
hainaut miss et nathan bon bah écoute
pour dire que moi tout va bien en tout
cas je sais pas comment ça va mais moi
je moi je me prends en main clairement
ça a bien changé un peu la ville à la
maison qui reconnaîtrait pas la maison
c'est un truc de ouf j'ai
bien rangé je passe l'eponge jeux la
cuisine je me fais des petits plats et
je fais de la muscu aussi un petit peu
notre moi tout va bien en tout cas moi
je t'aime toujours quoi comme un comme
avant rappelle moi monsieur c'est la
tomate oignon ah non mais je travaille
ici en fait je m'aime mètres cubes à
beast ah oui
écoute sébastien attends attends tu sais
c'est compliqué en ce moment le prix de
la manyu chabat et tu seras dans le
boulanger qui fait l'une je viens
lautren pardon patron des patrons toi il
faut virer sébastien n'attend pas ok ça
dégage ça dégage
allez un geste à toi vas t'en fut
souvent futiles
[Musique]
c'est nathan dans les moments difficiles
d'autant existence je suis sûr que ce
porte clé ce sera utile
hu
ça c'est de la bonne bibliothèque
municipale
là c'est à moi de jouer je peux le faire
assis là
[Musique]
vous
j'ai fait des recherches je te confirme
ans on a bien soucis avec le talisman
visiblement en moins 300 il a été maudit
par une tribu maya très très puissante
qui avait peur de son acura de pouvoir
et depuis mais quoi donc de parler
surtout si on reste dans une dimension
plus de 60 minutes à l'eau
[Musique]
mais la lie le technicien bâle s'est
complètement interdit un sursis
ce qu'il fait
j'ai passé toutes fabrique mais t'as pas
loin d'être leur vie dans la
bibliothèque municipale
alors qui va nous poser ce bouddha et
puis tu as le sentiment on a perdu tiens
c'est tout ce que vous croyez ça ça moi
ok en fait c'est mon grand père qui me
l'a offert sur son lit de mort
mon héritage poisson pour sa chance à
vous
wen en héritage il est dedans je peux
vous montrer aux copains pop up du haut
jours
on va tirer à la courte paille ça va le
tir d'un loup duff va vous faire un gros
tiana
ce que vous m'avez l'art adorable
messieurs comment moi j'suis personnes
monsieur personnes
il
il était là il sait comme de
l'actualiser
qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous à il se
souvient
je prends très bien est temps de mettre
les bibliothèques sont ouvertes c'est
mieux
vous avez quelque chose qui nous
appartient
donnez nous le talisman et tout se
passera bien ou getti
[Musique]